diese aufnahmen haben wenn den usa eine
welle der empörung ausgelöst
sie zeigen wie zwei afro amerikanische
männer in einem starbucks café in
philadelphia festgenommen werden
das personal hatte ihn nach
polizeiangaben störungen und unbefugtes
betreten vorgeworfen weil sie keine
bestellungen aufgaben
die beiden hätten angegeben auf einen
freund zu warten
der vorfall der bereits am donnerstag
passierte wurde von einem kunden gefilmt
und im internet verbreitet die bilder
lösten in philadelphia und darüber
hinaus proteste aus es wurden vorwürfe
laut die anzeige gegen die zwei
beschuldigten und die anschließende
festnahme seien nur wegen deren
hautfarbe erfolgt starbucks ließ
anschließend die anzeige gegen die
männer fallen und entschuldigte sich die
starbucks verantwortliche in
philadelphia karl-heinz stellte sich von
aufgebrachten demonstranten
wir wissen dass wir arbeit vor uns haben
wir haben sehr eng mit der gemeinschaft
hier in philadelphia zusammengearbeitet
es bricht mir das herz
auch konzernchef kevin johnson
entschuldigte sich öffentlich
es sei falsch gewesen die polizei
einzuschalten erklärte johnson
dieses vorgehen sei nicht repräsentativ
für die starbucks ziele und werte